you know Lindsey Graham during his
beautiful beautiful monologue rant
yesterday during the hearing and it
really was a thing of beauty I probably
watched it two or three more times last
night I watched the clip of it and you
know I said yesterday that it was it's
it's the greatest rant I've ever heard
from a politician ever in my life and
that's not even close to an exaggeration
I think by far it is and I still and I
still believe that the thing that made
it so great it wasn't just cathartic to
listen to although it was that but it
was also important okay not not just
important because of the you know a
effect it has in this particular
situation but important because I think
hopefully it showed something to other
Republicans which is you you got to just
be sick of this stuff you've got to just
be sick of this stuff from the left and
from Democrats and get angry and when I
say get angry I don't mean you know
there's there's the theatrical rehearsed
kind of Republican anger that you see
during campaigns and everything not
talking about that I'm talking about raw
and real where you're not worried about
trying to remain friends with these
people and you're not worried about how
it's gonna be awkward at the cocktail
party when you see them later but but
but really angry in an honest one of the
few times I've seen that from a
Republican and it was a great moment and
it was an important moment I think that
I hope that others other other
Republicans take note of it but he he he
said something he said to the Democrats
he said I would never do this to one of
your nominees and he pointed out that he
even voted for for Obama's nominees
which he shouldn't have done because
their judicial philosophies are
disastrous but either way the point is
he said I would never do this to one of
your nominees I would never tear them
ruin them like this like you're doing
and you know something that's true that
actually is true and I look I've I
criticized Republicans all the time I've
criticized Republicans more often than
I've criticized Democrats because
they're the
who are supposed to allegedly represent
me in my interests so their failures and
betrayals and everything are more
important to me and and and so that's
why I've criticized them so often but so
I'm gonna be the I'm not I'm the last
one to say that all Republicans are all
perfect and and all that stuff because
that's not true but it is true that
Republicans just they're not gonna sink
that low like Democrats will think about
this Republicans didn't want Merrick
garland confirmed right and and
Democrats still complaining about that
how look what you did to our nominee
well what did they do they just didn't
vote on and that's all they didn't want
to confirmed so they didn't vote on him
that's it and Merrick garland is yeah he
didn't get to be on the Supreme Court
fine but he can go and live his life and
do whatever he wants to do I assume he's
still a judge somewhere and you can do
whatever he wants in fact in the end he
probably be benefited to some degree by
it because his name got out there and
he's a sympathetic figure at least on
the left now and Republicans don't hate
him nobody hates him he's fine he
everything worked out fine for him so
that's all they didn't vote for him
Democrats though didn't want Brett
Kavanaugh confirmed so they accused him
of being a serial gang rapists and they
tried to ruin and destroy his entire
life they ripped him apart limb from
limb because they didn't want
Republicans Republicans could have tried
to do that too Merrick garland
considering they controlled the Senate
they controlled the timing of everything
and and and so they they could have dug
into his past tried to dig up skeletons
I have no idea if he has skeletons in
his closet or not but they could have
made-up skeletons if they wanted to I
mean they could have found someone
somewhere to make some kind of
accusation and and and then destroyed
his life that way but no instead they
just said we're not gonna vote on him
that's all and that's the difference in
fact let's look at recent history
conservatives are very willing to
criticize not just Republicans but like
my conservatives now they're very
willing to criticize their own in the
face of sexual assault allegations
so the liberal centers that are that are
say well the only reason why all the
conservatives are circling the wagon
around Kavanagh is because they want
them on the Supreme Court
no that's actually not the reason the
reason why conservatives are are now
they do want them on the Supreme Court
and there is quite a lot at stake here
the lives of children are literally at
stake here but so we do want them on the
Supreme Court but the reason why we're
circling wagons around them is because
we think these charges are bogus and
trumped-up and we think this whole thing
is a coordinated smear campaign because
that's the reason we're circling the
wagons but many conservatives came out
against Roy Moore matter how you felt
about that the fact is many
conservatives came out against them even
though that was a very important race
for good service many conservatives came
out against their own presidential
nominee a month before the election
after the access hollywood tape surfaced
now there are also conservatives who
will circle the wagons no matter what
but the point is that there does exist a
very sizeable chunk of conservatives who
have a certain standard that they do
apply relatively evenly and fairly to
everyone that just does not exist on the
left at all there might be a few a
random few diamonds in the rough who
have some kind of something approaching
a consistent standard maybe but there is
not at all any kind of sizable
preponderance of leftist who are willing
to apply the standard that they set on
that that are willing to take the
standard that they apply to
conservatives and apply it to their own
there they're just as there are almost
none who are willing to do that what
they're doing to Brett Kavanaugh they're
doing only because they hate him for his
ideology no other reason and because
they hate his ideology they will stop at
nothing and absolutely nothing think
about this there have been almost no
Democrats or liberals I want to say no
because I haven't seen any but maybe
there are one or two I don't know
so there have been almost no Democrats
or liberals who have even taken the
position that look
the Ford allegations seem serious let's
look into those okay the but these
others and I don't think that those
allegations are serious or credible but
this is I'm trying to describe what
might be a somewhat here's here's a
position that the Democrats are leftist
could take that is that at least
pretends to almost sort of be consistent
or semi fair kind of right in that
position would be the Ford allegations
yeah those are serious the stuff about
gang rape and and all that kind of stuff
that's absurd
no they're not they wouldn't even take
that position okay they won't even do
that they believe all of it all of it
they'll take all of it so they're not
going to
there's no discernment at all they say
yeah the Ford allegations are serious oh
this person's accusing this person over
here is accusing him of being a serial
gang rapist who was part of a rape
cartel a rape mafia with his other
friends and they would literally wait in
lines outside of doors
to rape unconscious women and they did
this on an almost weekly basis for years
at a time and nobody ever called the
police or anything like that there's no
evidence of it it never turned up an FBI
investigation yeah sure that's true
they'll take that too they'll take
anything anything at all if somebody
came forward and said that Brett
Kavanaugh is a serial killer and has has
murdered 50 prostitutes they take that
also they'd say yeah let's have an FBI
investigation into that it's not an
exaggeration they'll take anything the
Democrats on the committee yesterday
before Cavanaugh had even testified in
fact before the hearing itself but even
at the hearing at the hearing before his
testimony they said and there were at
least three at least three of them said
this
maybe they all did some version of it
they said to Christine Ford I believe
you
which means consider what that means you
at this hearing
you've got the accuser up there giving
her version which no again as we've gone
over no evidence no witnesses not only
no witnesses but in fact there are
witnesses that refute what she's saying
it doesn't remember remember when where
how she got there remembers almost
nothing except for Brett Kavanaugh
somehow she remembers that 100% and she
remembers the laughter and she remembers
a stairwell okay it's all she remembers
and she remembers conveniently that she
only had one beer she remembers that
absolutely nothing else okay
she's given her version the accused
hasn't even said a word yet at the
hearing and they have already said we
believe you to Ford which means yes
Brett Kavanaugh is a rapist they said
that they declared that without hearing
the other side just based on the
accusation and then Cavanaugh came out
and they demanded an investigation that
was the great thing you know rather than
ask the questions themselves they
demanded that Cavanaugh asked for the
FBI to ask the questions that they could
have just asked if they weren't too busy
asking him to ask the FBI to ask him and
by the way you're hearing from Democrats
and liberals that the confirmation this
is what you're hearing you're hearing
that the confirmation would only be
delayed by a week they're saying look
just delay it by a week that's all just
delay it by a week and have the FBI
investigate that's all we're asking for
it's no big deal just a week that's
reasonable and if you don't know any
better if your obtuse you hear that you
say well okay that's reason only a week
I mean what's it a week it's fine
right once once a week what's a week
after all this it's a lie they're liars
it will take a lot longer than a week
for the FBI to conduct an investigation
a lot longer we're talking
at least a couple of months easily law
easily eight or nine months and they
know that and that's the only reason the
only reason they want an FBI
investigation because here's the other
thing they know they know that the FBI
investigation will amount to nothing it
will do nothing because there's nothing
to investigate the accuser has told us
everything she remembers he/she
remembers almost nothing they don't even
have a location or a year for when this
happened there's nothing for them to
investigate let's leave a side the fact
that they don't investigate these kinds
of things because it's not a federal
crime a groping allegation against a 17
year old thirty five years ago is not a
federal crime it's not within the
purview of the FBI but even if a war
there's nothing to investigate
so all they're gonna do is just
interview and get statements from
everybody concerned which has already
happened but they know that they just
want to delay it until after the
midterms that's the only reason they are
such liars everything out of their mouth
is a absolute lie and even if it did
only take a week which it wouldn't but
I'm just saying even if it were only a
week or even if they found some other
excuse to delay things for a week
the reason why they'd want that week is
to dig up more allegations well the
point is they already passed their
verdict okay they already they already
passed their verdict they passed their
verdict before they heard from the
accused it's like a jury it's like a
it's like a jury hearing the Katyn that
the prosecutors case and then reaching
its verdict saying ok he's guilty so
then what's the point of an
investigation there's nothing nothing
that will ever make them change their
mind that's the one thing Breck haven't
I did a great job the one thing I wish
he had said which I'm not gonna
criticize him for not thinking to say
this
but given the circumstances I wouldn't
have done half as well as he did but
still he the one thing I wish he had
said to these Democrat senators who were
asking for an investigation I wish he
had said to them you snakes you already
said before I got up here that you
believe her so what do you want an
investigation for it you've already
condemned me what are you even asking me
questions for why should I even answer
your questions you're not trying to get
to the truth you've already made up your
mind there's nothing I could you nobody
should have said you should said senator
is there anything I could say or present
to you that would make you believe me
instead of dr. fort is there anything no
there's nothing they kept bringing up
mark judge they want to hear from mark
judge mark judge Brett Kavanaugh friend
from high school
subpoena mark judge well mark judge
already denied the allegations under
penalty of felony he's already given a
statement so he said no it didn't happen
there's only there's not here's the
thing if you're saying that a certain
event never occurred well then there's
nothing else to be said about your
second didn't happen so that's all I
can't I can't answer more questions
about a thing that I'm telling you
didn't happen that's all I can keep
saying is no but but and they already
got their note now if Mark judge had
said yeah this it happened the party was
there there was some kind of interaction
between between us and dr. Ford but it
wasn't quite like that right if he had
said something like that well then okay
yeah then you have a then you have a
very real reason for wanting him there
in front of you so that he could explain
okay so it did happen you're saying it
wasn't quite like that all then what
happened but there's no reason to have
him there and ask him what happened
because he already told you it didn't
happen do you can't say anything else
about a thing that didn't
except oh you keep saying yes didn't
happen didn't happen didn't happen
didn't happen didn't happen but they
want him there anyway so why do they
want him it let's think about it why why
do the Democrats want mark judge who was
already denied it why do they want him
there well they want him because he's
just a regular guy he's a he's a he's a
regular guy and he apparently has a
substance abuse problem which is what we
learned at the at the hearing yesterday
and so what they want to do is they want
to parade him in front of TV cameras and
rip him apart they want to take this guy
in his 50s been struggling with
substance abuse his whole life
apparently and we could only I know
nothing about his life whatsoever but
someone who has had the problems for
their whole lives you know you could
only imagine that there are many other
problems compounding on top of that
probably most of the time you know
problems with your family with work
somebody who has a substance struggling
with substance abuser to now in their
50s most likely that it has not been a
very happy life but just put it that way
so they want to take this guy and they
want to parade him in front of TV
cameras and they want to rip him apart
and dis ice extoll life every detail in
front of a national audience they want
to uh Turley ruin and eviscerate this
poor guy and then condemn Cavanaugh by
association because again there's
nothing to ask him about the event
because he's saying the event didn't
happen so they're not gonna it wouldn't
ask him about that at all I guarantee
you if they had if they had if they had
judge in front of them they would ask
him almost nothing they probably
wouldn't ask him a single question about
whether or not this thing even happened
they want to know all the nitty-gritty
details of his own personal drug use or
alcohol use and they will
all of that they want to know even years
where even later years where he and
Cavanaugh hardly saw each other and then
they don't even need to connect him to
Cavanaugh directly they all they want to
do is say look at this pitiful alcoholic
guy the Kavanagh was hanging around with
you see they don't need to connect the
dots all they need to do is it's guilt
by association
and so publicans of course aren't gonna
let them do that you think they'd have
any mercy on mark judge I don't know
they don't care I mean they would rip
him to pieces and leave him there just a
clump of matter sitting in front of him
and they don't care if he went home and
killed himself because of what they did
they couldn't care they couldn't
possibly care less not at all
someone asked me yesterday they asked me
how do we come back from this you know
with it seems like we've crossed some
kind of threshold here how do we come
back from it well I do think in one
sense we crossed a line to threshold we
entered a place where it really is now
just total war one side observes
absolutely no rules of morality or a
tacit or anything I mean they're even
saying now if they get into power that
they want to impeach Cavanaugh he's
confirmed
so that means Democrats are they getting
the power they want to impeach a sitting
Supreme Court justice and the president
so it's total war for them yeah we
should also keep in mind that we really
cross this threat threshold long ago and
now it's just out in the open
unmistakable but as I've said many times
we long ago entered a place where there
is no common ground between people no
chance of unity people are just living
in different universes I don't
understand how anyone could have watched
the hearing yesterday and come away
feeling like yeah that was fair on Brett
cab and all that was a fair process for
him I don't see how any human with a
Sol could think that but there are quite
a lot of humans who do in America and so
they they're at a different universe I
cannot there they are living in a
version of reality
I just can't relate to them it'd be like
trying to hang out with someone who like
just did heroin or something and you're
sober it's you you can't it's their
their mind is somewhere away over there
and what there's no it's like you try to
sit down to have a conversation with
someone like that you can't do it it's
like trying to sit down at a
conversation with someone who's who's
you know on LSD or something you can't
there's no way for you to do that
because they're up in the twilight zone
right and that's that's how it is with
the laugh they're permanently on LSD
they're permanently in the twilight zone
I said yesterday yeah I know it was a
very strong thing to say but I said
yesterday that as I was watching the
hearing all I could think about the
Democrats as I was watching their
performance all I could think is I'm
ashamed to share a country with them and
I I meant it and I still mean it one
other thing I want to say here there's a
talking point a really frustrating yet
predictable talking point from liberals
in the media and on social media from
Democrat politicians and everybody and
they're saying what they're saying is
that Cavanaugh was too angry yesterday
he was too angry someone that said that
some of them said that this means he
doesn't have the temperament to be a
Supreme Court justice others said that
this anger really lets you see how he
might rape somebody
I read someone on Twitter yesterday and
this was retweeted and liked thousands
of times but they said that watching the
hearing you could really picture
Cavanaugh putting his hand over
someone's mouth and raping them because
he was so angry now we uh we know
obviously that if he wasn't angry they
would have said the opposite they would
have said well an innocent man would be
angry in this situation he wasn't angry
where was his anger dr. Ford had a
motion he had no emotion so if he had no
emotions they would they would have said
he's an emotion
the sociopathic robot and they could
totally see how he might rape somebody
and if you shows emotion they're gonna
say oh he's an angry hothead I could
totally see how he raped somebody so no
matter what he does it does not matter
he's damned either way that's the whole
point here that's the whole that that's
why this whole process is a sham is
because the people who are accused you
are accusing him and orchestrating all
of this and who won them off of the
court it does not matter what happens
what he does what he says what evidence
is presented what witnesses come forward
none of that matters none of it matters
at all because he's already convicted in
their eyes period but I can't believe I
even have to explain this but let's just
okay yeah he was angry he was very angry
and I was I was glad to see that anger
not glad at the situation obviously but
I was glad that he let that anger out
and I can't believe that we even need to
talk about this but but but why was he
angry for anyone who's could if anyone
who might have watched the hearings or
is watching clips now and thinking oh my
goodness he's so angry I'm so it's I
anyone who feels scared or startled by
his anger why would he be angry I'm so
confused that's so so disturbing that
this guy's so angry well if anyone is
thinking that let me try to explain
imagine imagine that you have that
you're on the cusp of a say some kind of
what's even in in fact will even scale
this down okay will scale this down to
make it much smaller than what it
actually is for Brett Kavanaugh okay
because for Brett Kavanaugh this is
playing out on the national stage the
international stage really and he's
being slandered by the national media
and his whole life is being affect but
let's scale it down to something that's
more maybe you know more accessible so
imagine at work you were you're up for
some kind of promotion and there are
people at work who don't want you to get
that promotion because they want someone
else to get it and so they spread a
rumor that
you sexually harass maybe they start
with a rumor that you are a sexual
harasser and then as the as the days go
on the rumors that they're spreading
maliciously about you get more and more
serious and then they say that oh you uh
you know you even have groped a couple
of women at work and then and then
finally they come up with a story that
you raped a co-worker in the bathroom at
work right and so they're not even
they're not just trying to prevent you
from getting this promotion they're
trying to get you fired from your job
get you put in jail doesn't matter you
know if you end up in jail and divorced
fine with them they are trying to
utterly ruin you because you committed
the sin of performing really well at
work and putting yourself up for a
promotion so imagine that and imagine
that went on for two weeks
would that make you angry how would you
feel after two weeks of that after two
weeks of these lies then you've worked
so hard your whole life you've got to
the point where you've earned a
promotion and now not only is the
promotion gonna be taken from you but
everything in your life is about to be
taken your job your marriage your
reputation everything based on these
lies rumors innuendoes would that make
you angry how would you feel about that
and if you got a chance to confront the
people of orchids or castrated this how
would you approach it would you say well
gee guys I really don't appreciate this
I really don't gee would you stop trying
to destroy my life and my marriage in my
family would you please you know I'd
really appreciate it if you would stop
would you mind oh you wouldn't mind okay
well then continue sorry I didn't mean
to continue yes could continue to
continue destroying me is that how you
is that what you would say or would you
do a prick haven't I did
and would you be furious and angry and
yelling well of course no you would take
the latter option because you're a human
being
responding as any human being would so
what do you expect Brett kaznia is he
not allowed to be a human being is he
not allowed to be indignant is he not
allowed to feel angry at what has
happened not only to him but his family
yeah I think angers is totally
appropriate here and anyone who would
try to hold it against him that he's
angry well anyone like that
that's just disingenuous at best all
right been a long week everybody have a
good weekend talk to you next week
Godspeed